we're already in the second week of July
2019 so I'm a little bit behind on doing
this monthly update video in which I'll
talk about what we've got coming up this
month and what went on in the last month
which was quite busy I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
so here they are big thing number one
I've got a recording of my presentation
to the Aristotle and the Aristotelian
tradition conference on thumos which
many of you may find quite interesting
given that's the part of us that gets
angry
the second thing big thing number two
coming up this month a little bit later
we're going to have another video
premiere of a video this time about the
epicurean tradition and how to carry out
self-directed study on that school of
philosophy and then finally this month
the big thing number three I'm going to
bring out the email class that I've been
promising for a while in the study with
sadler teachable Academy so those are
the three big things June was quite a
busy month as I think some of you know
already from my postings in social media
I attended the Aristotle and wrist
Italian tradition conference and
presented a paper there and of course
you know got to meet and greet other
people and give comments on their papers
as well I did a video premiere on the
stoicism self-directed study that's a
new series that I've been doing I
managed to get to my Hegel Q&A s and I
did my monthly AMA as well which you can
find link to below
I didn't unfortunately
make it to the worlds of speculative
fiction presentation that I was going to
do that's been delayed so we'll do Piers
Anthony later on don't whine we had some
medical issues and the biggest reason
why I didn't get all that much
accomplished was because I was getting
things accomplished in another important
field in my life my kids were visiting
for summer visit
and since I don't get to spend an awful
lot of time with them already because
they live two states away I try to
maximize the amount of time so I you
know put off any new obligations that I
was going to possibly incur I told
people that I'd talk with them about new
tutorials or talks or consulting laid
around in July and I'm starting to get
to those now my my daughter did a series
of tours of University of
wisconsin-milwaukee programs here so
that was a lot of fun for both her and I
and we did a lot of local events and
festivals we went to the swing park
where they have these adult swings and
you can do some you know sort of urban
hiking as well and we went to the museum
several times got to go swimming
got to go down by the lake some of you
have seen the pictures of that but most
of what we did was just living together
as a family and enjoying our time
together we did some cooking we watched
some shows and movies you know we played
some games we got to go to Comic Con
here the Wisconsin comic-con Summerfest
pride a whole bunch of different cool
things at the same time I have not had a
break from teaching
I jumped immediately from you know
spring into summer teaching and June saw
me working on two different classes my
existentialist philosophy and literature
class with Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design which finished up just a few
weeks ago I also started the Milwaukee
Area Technical College ethics class
which is the seven weeks seven week
class going on as well doing editing of
course for stoicism today and some
arrangement of you know the upcoming
events in the fall I got a little bit of
writing done not too much and for my
long-standing clients I also did get to
do some tutorial work and philosophical
counseling
and consulting I turned out a lot of
video production not all of which has
been released at this time because I use
these videos in my online classes so
four core concept videos I released the
Marcel videos I think I also released
some SART videos or it might have been
Rilke in the month of June as well and
then for my ethics class I shot material
on Ruth Benedict meri Midgley some stuff
on David Hume you know for the early
parts of that and I've released all of
that video material as well and then
there of course was the Sadler's advice
about self-directed study the stoic
philosophy the entire school we released
that video as well and I also released a
bit of podcast material not as much as I
would have liked but it was a great
month because I got to spend time with
my kids in summer a lot of fun you know
activities and some good downtime and a
lot of good conversations that we had in
July now that my kids are actually back
home I'm buckling down and getting to a
lot of work that I've been waiting to
get through I also have some events
coming up this month that you might be
interested in if you're here in the
Milwaukee area on Thursday the 11th at 7
p.m. at the Brookfield Public Library
we're going to resume the worlds of
speculative fiction series with Gordon
Dixon's a child or Doris I depending on
how you you want to look at it
novels we're gonna have some great
discussions about that on the twelfth
which is a Saturday at 12 p.m. I'll be
having my online AMA session
I should mention all times for online
events are central time so you want to
check your time zone on the 16th from at
5:00 p.m. we're going to have our public
Hagel Q&A and discussion that's another
online session everybody's welcome to
join in you don't
to be a supporter of the half-hour Hagel
project you could just jump right in
something that is underwritten by my
patreon supporters on the 20th we have
two events coming up at 12 p.m. we'll
have the video premiere for the
Epicurean school self directed study and
philosophy video so if you you know want
to get in on that and ask me questions
or comments and get you know my
responses in real time that is something
you want to put on your calendar at 2:00
p.m. will be having the patreon
exclusive hagel Q&A and discussion
session which is for supporters of the
half-hour Haegele project then on
Thursday the 25th 6:00 p.m. at the
Shorewood Public Library we have the
Milwaukee stoic fellowship where we will
be discussing some marcus aurelius and
talking about some of the stoic
practices that we have been trying to
implement over the last month and
finally on the 27th at 3 p.m. another
online event
my philosophy chat session for patreon
supporters at a certain level so if you
want to get in on that you want to check
out the patreon site I'm now doing a lot
of catch-up and a lot of correspondence
catching up with friends colleagues also
clients I've had a lot of people you
know writing me over the summer saying
they wanted to start philosophical
counseling start tutorial sessions so
I'm slowly phasing those in as well and
meeting with people who I haven't been
seeing over the last you know a couple
months or so because I've been so busy I
am finishing up the ethics class with
MATC Milwaukee Area Technical College
and just yesterday I started my business
ethics online six weeks week class with
Marquette up shooting a lot of content
for that not all of which is going to be
made publicly available but may show up
in my teachable Academy down the line
you know working through what I like
about it and
when I don't like I'm also in the
process of doing a lot of course
building for fall I'm teaching a class
in the second chance Pell program which
is for prisoners so I have to have the
entire class ready to run as an online
class before classes begin so I'm
building that out this this month and
I'm also starting to build out my other
fall classes my intro to humanities
class for Milwaukee area Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design
if I get my you know class shells my
foundations classes for Marquette I'm
building a business ethics class for
Carthage College and also working in
another class for my aunt's so it's
gonna be a very very busy fall and I
want to have as much prep work done as
possible video work I'm going to be
shooting a lot of core concept stuff but
I also have some stuff in reserve that
I'm unrolling because I I got a little
bit ahead of the schedule of you know
the production schedule is quicker than
the release schedule so you can look
forward to seeing some more AJ air
videos I've got some videos on cow moos
myth of sisyphus I've got some videos on
Simone de Beauvoir is the second sex I'm
a few other things that I need to shoot
here and there for my classes that are
coming up in the fall I'm hoping to
resume shooting Haegele videos it was
just impossible to do while my kids were
here it takes a lot of presence of mind
to shoot those videos but now I can get
back into it I'm going to shoot some
more personal videos since people have
been asking for them and I've got some
book reviews that are long overdue given
my schedule and I'd like to get them out
so I'm going to be doing that as I
mentioned I'm shooting a lot of footage
for the business ethics class so that is
going to keep me pretty busy if you
couldn't show up at the online events or
if you're here in the area at the
in-person events they'll be happy to
engage with you hope all of you have a
great month and I'll see you next time
maybe see you in the am a session coming
up this weekend
you